it's a great time to become a lean dog
and all it takes is less than 30 minutes
once or twice a week I stopped by a new
local gym to show you what that means
I heard it takes a lean dog to run a
long race and that is why we're here at
lean Dog Fitness you guys have been open
since July Nate you're the general
manager just tell us what the mission is
here the mission for lean Dog Fitness is
to improve human longevity we combine
Elite personal trainers with exclusive
technology to give you the best workout
experience on the planet okay I like
where you're headed now your founder is
a perfect example of that right he
certainly is Tom Harmon is 72 years old
doesn't know a doctor and you can tell
he gets a good workout in what an
introduction how do you feel about that
thanks
it's always great to work with it so
he's always got the positive attitude
yeah absolutely but some 92 don't know a
doctor there's a lot of people out there
who are wondering what your secret is
how does this how is this unique here
it's really good exercise really good
food really good nutrition so it is kind
of like the trifecta and we definitely
focus on the really good exercise that's
perfect for the individual very stylized
so let's talk about the exercises here
ARX adaptive resistance it allows a
person who's very strong like a friend
here to push a lot of weight and then
resist a lot of weight so he's fully
engaged throughout the entire repetition
so he only has to do one set of maybe
six and then he's done and then it
allows them to in 15 minutes to get a
full week's worth of strength training
yeah wow so I assume you know
professional athletes use these machines
as well absolutely it's it's very well
thought of in the NFL and there's a lot
of Hollywood action stars that like use
this stuff too because it is so
efficient yeah okay
ours but also our real life Heroes we
got astronauts using the bathroom
machine we do we do and and NFL uses
this for rest rehab and Recovery it's uh
it combines cold with compression and
then a high intensity interval training
so when a person sits down they get they
go through an elliptical training but
they're kept nice and cool and uh it's
nice and intense but it's not
overbearing or anything like that and
then afterwards they lay on the cold
table again using that cold for rehab
and Recovery now I heard this method is
also called the Fountain of Youth yeah
that's because the cold and compression
tricks your pituitary gland into kicking
into gear which provides all those
beneficial anabolics that help us repair
and recover and make us feel younger
maybe I know that's music to people's
ears Fountain of Youth but also it's
only about a 20 minute workout only 21
minutes and then a 10 minute rest on the
cold bed and you're all feeling revived
and refreshed and you just head on out
the door and we'll see you in a few days
okay what I also love about about this
gym is you track people's progress that
come through here we do we have the fit
3D scanner which takes 1200 images of
you while you rotate and uh which then
breaks out at an extremely detailed
analysis of where you are today or where
you were a month ago and compares the
two that's amazing this is perfect so
run over here back to Nate because we're
2023 and a lot of a lot of people are
wondering how they can optimize their
body so how can they become members easy
you can book for free on
leandogfitness.com to receive a two-week
free trial of our training or you can
book in person with our concierge all
right simple as that now it takes a lean
dog to run a long race and I hear that's
a quote from your dad yes it is he was a
drill instructor in the Army so he had
no patience for people that were lazy so
he kept us moving pretty good yeah
you're making him proud sir
thank you lean Dog Fitness for
sponsoring that segment you can find
them in Henderson give them a call at
702-996-6372 or visit leandogfitness.com
for more information now they do have a
very special offer for you you can get
two weeks of free training through
December 31st